[Music]
so we all
how do we feel about tom cruise i'm a
fan i'm a fan i like i like tom cruise
yeah not mad maverick is dope yeah i
haven't seen him jack reacher
for the i was like but i was also like
in high school and you know what and i
was like i didn't really like him but
then in that movie i was like he's
actually believable as a badass yeah
he's pretty believable as a japanese
person too he is yeah he played a really
good japanese man i i don't mind it is
interesting to start seeing uh him with
like he looks old now
so you know to the point where he has to
even in maverick hey he has to play
older people roles kind of like what
happened with jackie chan and the
foreigner or like
sylvester stallone and like the
expendables or whatever you know what i
mean it looks like he's finally at that
age the old guy well you can't hide it
in botox you can't do mission possible
seven look like a mission possible three
you know what i mean what's gonna be
mission impossible is him actually doing
movement during the mission yeah i think
so he's always going to have the run
though the run is good the run is so
good and that dude that somebody put
that together a couple years ago i
didn't even notice that he runs like
that so much way better than stevenson
he's got a good run yeah stevenson
doesn't run anymore he runs like it cuts
to his back and then his body double
runs everyone's like a little [ __ ] dude
does he still have a wig
cigar oh yeah dude it's crazy hilarious
it's really funny you just switch to
hats or beans or some [ __ ] imagine with
a beanie it's too late it's too late
come on dude so that pronounced v
widow's peak is pretty wild
it's a yeah it's a hard angle i just
hope tom cruise doesn't end up like rock
hudson where like if tom cruise is
actually gay i hope he any if he wants
to come out i hope he can do it before
he dies do you think he's gay that's the
rumor
dude but if he is if he is oh i thought
that was leonardo dicaprio not that
point everyone thinks tom cruise is gay
for sure yeah and they think that he and
him and travolta because travel all the
scientology guys right yeah yeah yeah
i'm about to say i was about to ask he's
a scientist even will smith people say
that about will smith i thought every
actor in hollywood just experimented i
thought that every guy who's not me is
gay because i'm jealous of them
oh that too that's accurate i subscribe
to that too you know i feel you your
straightness just makes everyone look
gay yeah i'm just like um that guy's
probably gay because i'm really jealous
of him i can see how you're gonna be
wrong about that usually but everyone in
this room is a gay for
sure it's a spectrum so much sex right
and then they have so many drugs and
parties and orgies that like hey if
you're having that many orgies you might
just be like curious and be like you
know what this round
travolta i'll try and you grab his dick
and you suck it
or or is it one of those things or is it
one of the things where it's like i
agree you're you're tom cruise you're
travolta you're getting so much [ __ ] so
much [ __ ] so much that you're you're
doing giant orgies so big on sandra
bullock's ass like every week so
desensitized and this guy's dick is
already out you know
so decent size we're already here it's
all the girls didn't show up this time
but we already popped the viagra every
brazilian model that exists yeah it's
like it's like you're telling me if you
woke up and there was a churro on your
pillow next to your mouth you wouldn't
just go
yeah yeah i'm gonna take a bite
you think do you think anyone would take
a bite do you think they called tom
cruise and you're like like dicaprio and
tom cruise is on the phone they're like
dude man we [ __ ] really hot girls
everything but you know what i haven't
had is a real good strong man me too i
haven't had a strong man either you're
like but i don't want just anything that
was the right voice for a strong man
yeah
i don't want any guy you know what i
want you i just hope it's not a death
bed situation like rock hudson okay so
what movie do you think tom cruise i
don't know i'm gonna start experimenting
that's something rock hot city was like
a heartthrob of like old cinema back in
the day and he was like the man's man
back man uh-huh and then he was a clint
eastwood
how do you know he was telling the truth
or cause you that's a funny ass troll to
die by it's like yo i got one joke for
them i'm gay and then just dies and
you'll never know bro is that like
freddie mercury where everyone was like
oh he's like the rock god and then he's
like he comes out and everyone's like
oh what
i think so maybe maybe during that time
pretty much get it right i think i
thought it was or that era i'm just like
thinking guys in that era oh hairbands
were very gay so i think it was
like except slayer but yeah and they
loved it like they loved gay culture
like prince dressed that way like it was
like cool i thought they were so macho
they didn't even they couldn't even have
a gaydar was it like known but taboo
what just like you know but nobody talks
about it i don't know i don't know
formally formally you know what i mean
because liberace was super gay yeah and
like that era was pretty taboo yeah well
and he liked young he liked the myanmar
oh really yeah he liked it like he like
apprentice level game also it's it's
kind of interesting that when when you
look at like bands like poison or
whatever back in the day the hair bands
it looks gay to people looking back but
at the time it was just defiant yeah it
wasn't necessarily they were they were
being called gay by like country guys or
like guys that like all the hair bands
they're like oh look at these girly
dudes the guys they were defying
probably my grandpa in the audience was
calling him yeah yeah but it's it's kind
of like the way they call bts like
feminine and all that [ __ ] but it's not
as bad as feminine effeminate effeminate
feminine yeah but it's funny that that
like something like that would be like
the ladies [ __ ] loved that [ __ ] just
like yeah like bts just like guns and
roses and [ __ ] isn't there something to
that and i don't know but isn't there
something that where it's like their
their features are so soft they're not
like it's not like intimidating or some
[ __ ] so yeah it's been like that for a
really long time but then uh they did
the same thing with boy bands in the 90s
you know like but but it's like it's the
age of women that are into them right
but boy bands it's it's it's
non-threatening you know yeah like high
school it's like in the simpsons when
lisa has that magazine and someone else
has teen beat tiger b then hers is
non-threatening boys yeah
yeah it's a flavor it's a [ __ ]
threatening voice anyway so tom cruise
he um
you know we're all
we all love tom cruise i think everyone
knows tom cruise i'm a fan so he's dead
and i'm kidding
you tried to [ __ ] me today can you
imagine if he really got that headline
right now and that's the delivery with
the way he films his movies where he's
actually doing these stunts i keep
expecting every time you see tom
cruise's headline oh please did he get
like super [ __ ] up on the last mission
impossible he like broke his leg or
something yeah but that's the whole
story line out of maverick right this is
partly why i really want to see it is
because
all the actors all the [ __ ]
interviews that they do they're all
talking about the crazy training that
they did for this movie like they did
actual like flight simulation also val
kilmer is in a bad condition too so oh
yeah they put him in here
they put him in it oh he's good and his
voice is not his real voice it's ai
computer generated because he has throat
cancer or something yeah so apparently
he like begged to be in the movie
because he wasn't originally supposed to
be scripted into it begged to be in it
they put him in it he moves his lips and
stuff and uh literally they use ai from
all the voice acting or anything wow no
wonder okay you'll see why his character
is the way he is i didn't know that
about him they did that for the mr
potato head guy too
and the latest like toy story oh no yeah
the guy that died they just did that
with james earl jones too because
there's a star wars show right now with
an obi-wan kenobi and james earl jones
um it's his voice doing vader which is
like the iconic voice but it wasn't him
recording he computer generated they
just ai like filled in the blank you've
been watching that show was it good
[ __ ] bomb dude i mean there's some
like weird it's okay
oh you think it's okay i think i just
love the character too much i think i'm
guys
i i'm still very happy to watch it but
i'm i'm
i think it's okay lukewarm i think that
there's some weird choices in it like i
don't get why he was like shooting all
those stormtroopers and then all of a
sudden he just lays down the ground like
what the [ __ ] dude what the [ __ ] is
anybody else watching or does anybody
else my mom was watching an episode and
i watched like 10 minutes of it and i
left
i'm a huge fan of [ __ ] you man what the
hell happened to tom cruise yeah is tom
who's it live or not so back to tom
cruise um
dude
he was visiting larry ellison you guys
know him he's like oracle ceo he's a
billionaire um hawaiian island shortly
after the dude bought it and he's
driving one of his [ __ ] expensive ass
cars
and he [ __ ] flipped and totaled it
whoa tonkus totaled larry's car in his
car while driving on his private island
on larry ellison's private house holy
he bought it for 300 mil in 2012. it's
not even a small island it's like huge
it's like the fourth one or some [ __ ]
you know that larry ellison's worth 86.9
billion dollars 86 and he only bought an
island of hawaii for 300 million that's
so crazy
i feel like things got to be sold in
ratio and not market value he owns 98
percent of the island of lanai he
doesn't own most of it yeah no he has
98. i mean he owns most of yeah um
[Laughter]
what i wanted to say understandable
um so when i have your own lanai has two
four seasons resorts a bunch of private
houses commercial properties but most of
it's larry ellison's which is [ __ ]
bananas dude i went there but i wasn't
able to leave the airport because during
that time in hawaii you had to have a
covet test for island hopping
so oh wow
we
um uh we took a plane to just get to the
airport we just we're just
on a flight school thing right so then
we went down
you need to get some uh pilot flight
hours and then i was like can we use the
bathroom at the airport they said yeah
and then they're like but you can't
leave though because you didn't have
your coveted test and i'm like i hit it
we we went back to oahu but i was like
[ __ ] man i wanted to check out lanai but
dude tom cruise is [ __ ]
indestructible that's what i'm saying
he's never been back he's car flipped so
he's he's driving a toyota land cruiser
that belonged to larry ellison while
driving on lanai's mostly unpaved roads
right so that maybe contributed to it
but he's probably [ __ ] driving like a
maniac because tom cruise yeah and so
then practice stunt driving yeah dude
then he flips it totals it the car is
totally [ __ ] tom cruise is fine no
scratches no scratches and that's kind
of what i'm getting in here because we
we do you see the [ __ ] mission
impossible stunt where he's actually
hanging on the side of the plane they
filmed it okay you guys fearless to be
fair though yeah only because we also
lived in the era of jackie chan
isn't that not impressive john cruz's
stunts are different so his stunts
aren't necessarily like bodily physical
stuff it's death defying and daring no
so he'll like go on a plane and he'll
like lock himself in stuff but jackie
will like jump from a third story mall
thing try to hold his trash
is what i'm trying to get at
why do you bring up jackie chan i agree
jackie chan is the man i [ __ ] love
jackie
would be like falling from a building
and just be on cardboard boxes
jackie just doesn't want no trouble and
then he keeps on finding a lot of trolls
right now
no i thought the tom cruise i'm just
saying the different tiered stunts
you know what though tom cruise is hella
gangster because on maverick he rides a
motorcycle without helmet and i was like
well spoiler no we haven't even seen it
all right now i don't want to watch it
because i was really looking forward to
that morning that really stood out to me
beyond all the other stunts because i
was like that is probably the most
dangerous thing that you could do and
it's illegal dude anthony's doing some
wiggly [ __ ] though you see that because
now we can't you can't just talk about
something that you think it's cool
yeah wiggly [ __ ] because now you can't
talk about something that you think is
cool it's one up anthony over here or
it's like oh yeah well how come nobody's
talking about jackie chan it's like
yeah everyone loves jackie chan what fun
are you talking about drinking rocks
well neil armstrong with the [ __ ]
space
there's nobody talking about that right
now what about buzz dude buzz aldrin
what's this guy just like paid him
because he wanted to see a live action
stunt permission impossible bro that
seems very likely um give tom cruise's
little dubai abu dhabi or uh the uh
what's the what's the top building name
the um burj khalifa
that was a crazy one from which which
one this impossible uh ghost protocol
goes where he's doing the suction cups
and he's like literally on the outside
of burj khalifa but that's what he does
so much better than jackie you know
because that's what i was really getting
at is that it was cg though it was he
does cinematic stunts where like it's
when you're filming it you cannot
believe what you're looking at like in a
way that i think nobody else does
including especially jackie actually
especially
[Laughter]
i get it if you say vin diesel but don't
say jack [ __ ] he doesn't you can call
mr chan for all that vin diesel's not in
the conversation bro
can we get some credit for justin long
getting hit with dodge balls for real
and a wrench would anybody talk about
that shout out justin long dude
familia
meet amelia
[Music]